so let's try once more attack sorry
you're back on the air let's see if it
will hold and moderators please look
into what's going on go ahead attack
yeah it's totally fine technical issues
happen right anyway so basically my my
my issue is it seems to me that a lot of
um especially very progressive and very
conservative american media when it
comes to foreign policy analysis seem to
fall over themselves trying to justify
the actions of other authoritarian
states so i mean you've had for instance
tucker carlson you know making his
insane positions about russia that
actually they're the good guys in the
ukraine conflict and i feel even on
progressive media you have people like
you know hassan abi for instance who
will say that the us is the aggressor in
the ukraine crisis and i'm just
wondering if it just comes from this
impulsive idea that anytime the u.s
takes a position the u.s is by default a
bad actor or if it just comes from
almost a lack of knowledge on these
issues especially when it comes to
issues like ukraine where
every realistically speaking the us held
a secondary role and why ukraine even
came to the situation as in today yeah
so we have a very interesting situation
going on here in the us and you're
really getting to it
there are some on the right that are
increasingly defending authoritarian
states
because they're authoritarian and they
like authoritarian states there are some
on the left that are increasingly
defending authoritarian states some
because they also like authoritarian
states but
others
because they see
opposition to those states as promoting
american imperialism and i am sometimes
criticized i will say on the show maybe
you even heard me say
uh i am against the chavez maduro regime
in venezuela because i am an
anti-authoritarian and they are
authoritarian and i give 10 reasons why
and then people will say you imperialist
yankee encouraging intervention in
venezuela and i go wait when did i say
that i didn't say that at all
um and so being against authoritarianist
uh authoritarian regimes that are
putatively left
is used as a proxy to call you an
imperialist so we're seeing it from both
sides for slightly different reasons
yeah i agree and it seems really weird
to me that you will see some people in a
progressive circles you know um justify
the actions of an incredibly right-wing
almost fascistic state like russia which
has engaged in incredible oppression of
homosexual people even minorities
absolutely
and on the right it makes the very
little sense to me because at the same
time you know the very anti-muslim brite
seems to um follow over the hills to
praise putin when for instance putin has
a literal islamist dictatorship in the
southern part of russia in chechnya led
by a literal islamist who puts gay
people in concentration camps absolutely
and one of the catch phrases you have to
watch out for is
if you levy a critique on
um
china with the uyghurs
uh venezuela
russia what whatever
and then the reaction you get is the us
also does that stuff
that should be a red flag because it's
like yes
and i criticized the u.s for it as well
right i mean it's like i can criticize
both and be against invading russia and
still think that some of the things
they're doing are horribly authoritarian
the problem is a lot of people don't
really want to have that conversation
they just want to say you're an
imperialist
yeah i agree and in many ways it feels
weird to me because like you know being
from denmark obviously the media
perspective here is a bit different um
it seems to me that there is a general
consensus among left-wing and right-wing
media in denmark even among the more you
know socialistic and also more national
conservative elements yes russia is
indeed acting completely out of turn in
the ukraine crisis um
and it seems to me like it almost in the
u.s has just turned into another thing
where you can attack whoever is in power
currently so if donald trump were in
power then conservatives would probably
be like oh donald trump is showing
strength against russia by talking about
sanctions and now because in power it's
just oh biden he wants to destroy uh
america by doing sanctions against
russia and destroying everything it
feels like it's just a part of this like
hyper-partisan landscape in american
politics 100
100 listen where in denmark are you
i'm in our house oh okay i i'm familiar
with that that's a beautiful beautiful
uh it's like a small city right
yeah so our house is actually the second
largest city in denmark but that doesn't
say a lot because uh denmark isn't
exactly a very populous country yes but
yeah i um i study here i'm actually
originally from northern germany there's
a danish minority in northern germany
that i'm from okay and so i moved to i
moved to denmark in uh 2017 to study and
i'm doing my master's degree currently
in european studies so obviously
european politics is very interesting to
me got it well listen i one of the
places i've enjoyed the most in the
world is denmark what's the name of
these like open-faced sandwiches that
are so popular
ah smearable yes yes uh those are
delicious aren't they
yeah the funny thing is um so my mom is
actually american and she cannot
pronounce that at all yeah i'm not even
trying i don't think there's even a
possibility i could pronounce it
uh all right attack from uh from from
our huss denmark really appreciate the
call
thanks for taking my call david all
right there we go folks and that is
going to do it for calls today we will
take more calls
and i hope to hear from you the next
time we're going to take a quick break
and be back with more